pourquoi
[Musique]
bonjour à tous
êtes vous prêt à vos masques c'est la
rentrée comme les deux cent cinquante
mille élèves de franche-comté france 3
ce matin a pris le chemin de l'école
pour une édition spéciale consacrée à
cette rentrée scolaire une rentrée
exceptionnelle en raison bien sûr de
l'épidémie le coronavirus nous sommes
ici dans les vosges saônoises sans
barthélémy c'est une petite commune nous
sommes sont pleine campagne ici sont
scolarisés des élèves en maternelle mais
aussi en école primaire ils viennent de
cette commune et aussi des deux autres
communes alentour la matinée c'est déjà
terminé la cloche a bien sonné on est
avec le directeur de l'établissement mon
jour en jour nicolas lukasik comment
s'est passée cette rentrée forcément pas
comme les autres qu'est ce qui a changé
par exemple dans l'accueil des enfants
ce matin alors bas me principalement ce
qui a changé c'est de vraiment d'essayer
de travailler son regard avec les
enfants de se rapprocher leur dire
bonjour les rassurer pour les nouveaux
est-ce qui vous ont pas vu avec le
masque
alors on avait quand même travailler un
petit peu en amont pour leur envoyer des
images de nous-mêmes avec et sans le
masquer et puis les autres voilà on a
essayé vraiment les attirer par le
regard parfois la part d'autres manières
et avec les petits ont fait qu'en fait
du lavage de mains quand même fait du
gel hydroalcoolique comment on va s'en
va se laver régulièrement alors nous en
maternelle on va se laver régulièrement
plutôt les mains ou lavabo avec des
petites chansons des petites comptines
et on essaye d'éviter au maximum les
gels hydroalcooliques et puis vous avez
vous n'avez pas reçu tous les enfants en
même temps vous avez choisi en fait de
différer un petit peu la rentrée pour
certains c'est ça pour les plus petits
les petites sections qui sait leur peau
qui c'est la première rentrée on a
essayé de ménager
on le voit en tout cas un les familles
ont dû se préparer à cette rentrée une
rentrée hors norme pour elle regardez le
reportage tourné par anthony halpern et
antoine laroche dans une famille dans
une commune toute proche à monde souffre
presque six mois plus tard elle n'a pas
oublié le chemin de l'école anne elle
s'apprête à passer en cm1 son petit
frère en cp pour eux c'est enfin le jour
de la rentrée la rentrée et je suis
content de revenir à école parce que je
vois mes copines et s'il revoit la
maîtresse bonne journée pour ce jour
spécial
rien ne doit être laissé au hasard la
veille au soir
l'heure est aux dernières vérifications
des cartables la maman hélène fourni à
chacun de ses trois enfants plusieurs
masques pour toute la journée
même s'ils ne sont pas obligatoires en
primaire on a essayé de faire ça avant
de partir en vacances en fait comme ça
voilà quand augmenterait on savait qu'on
avait juste à vérifier les cartables
avec la liste qu'on nous a fourni à la
fin de l'année scolaire et puis pour
être un peu moins stressés et de se dire
qu'on avait oublié quelque chose
les fournitures c'est bien mais le plus
important c'est quand même la tenue à
nesle l'a choisie avec le plus grand
soin elle a prévu un ensemble neuf c'est
ce que j'ai acheté ya pas longtemps et
j'étais assis le t-shirt là parce qu'il
ya une corne dessus et j'aime bien les
licornes seules dispositions imposées
par l'établissement
la prise de la température chaque matin
est 36,5 cm direction toilettes
un dernier contrôle passé sans encombre
avant de retrouver les goûts et nous
sommes toujours avec le directeur du
pôle éducatif de saint barthélémy
nicolas lukasik comment avez vous
préparé les parents à cette rentrée il
fallait aussi les informer sur les
masquer ce qu'ils pouvaient venir pas
venir comment ça s'est passé avec eux
l'appareil c'est un travail en amont où
on les informe par mail principalement
parfois par téléphone pour les rassurer
et puis voilà on leur explique bien
pourquoi on porte le masque pourquoi on
l'est on évite de les faire entrer dans
l'école
plusieurs les enfants ne porte pas de
masque 1 e 1 puisqu'ils ont tous en
dessous de 11 ans et 11 ans la limite
obligatoire
est ce qu'il ya des parents qui ont eu
peur qu'ils ne voulaient pas remettre
leurs enfants non honnêtement on a eu
zéro cas de
parents qui ne voulaient pas mettre
leurs enfants à l'école message des
petites questions simples sur les
échanges de matériel
al'inverse est ce qu'il y avait au
contraire des parents et des enfants qui
étaient très impatients de revenir parce
que pour certains ça fait loin y en a
qui sont pas revenus depuis le
confinement oui oui on a des beaucoup de
parents qui s'étaient prêtés de nous
voir de retourner avec les copains donc
c'était important en tout cas comment
vous avez senti les enfants ce matin
justement heureux d'être là de la
nouveau oui plutôt heureux oui oui
plutôt heureux alors que les petites
inquiétudes sur les nouveaux maîtres etc
mais au global mans est heureux de venir
et horizons finalement on passe assez
vite ce côté ce masque c'est ça oui oui
avec doit rentrer en comprend d'autres
choses pour elle travaille alors il est
presque midi c'est l'heure de la cantine
pour certains d'autres se retourne et de
leurs familles on imagine que les
parents sont impatients de savoir
comment s'est passée cette première
matinée on retrouve devant les grilles
de l'école maxime le nouveau maxime
bonjour bonjour bonjour à tous va
effectivement je me trouve juste devant
envoyé la cour de récréation et puis la
cantine qui se trouve juste derrière moi
et pour savoir comment s'est passée
cette première rentrée je suis avec
ludivine tu as chaud et son fils léo qui
a 7 ans alors les une première question
pour toi tu rentrais ce matin en séance
et sa wii alors expliquez nous comment
ça s'est passé très bien la retrouver
tes copains oui pas trop stressé bon
visiblement tout se passe bien pour les
eaux pour sa maman ludivine expliquez
nous c'est toujours stressant une
rentrée des classes
oui il ne rentrait des cracks là c'est
toujours stressant
cette année à mon avis ça s'est bien
passé donc ça va alors on le voit vous
avez le masque nous portons aussi parce
qu'évidemment il ya ce contexte de colis
de 19
est-ce que vous à ça vous a causé un peu
de stress supplémentaire
une préparation enfin quand est-ce que
vous avez réorganiser votre votre
rentrée non pas du tout en fait il faut
apprendre maintenant à vivre avec le
colline
donc nous a respectés les gestes
barrière à les faire respecter par les
enfants est autrement
non ça a été voilà globalement
satisfaite de cette rentrée oui oui
parce qu'en fait le pôle éducatif nous a
bien aussi entendre et nous avons reçu
pas mal de mails avec toutes les
consignes qu'il fallait respecter
donc il suffisait de suivre ce qu'on
nous disait tout simplement merci
beaucoup lui dit ville alors justement
pour évoquer ce pôle périscolaire on va
retrouver juste à côté de moi francis
ouzou qui le maire de saint-barthélémy
c'est la commune où nous nous trouvons
bonjour monsieur missionnaire on a le
pôle périscolaire expliquez nous qu'est
ce qu'il y a de l'activité en
périscolaire proposé ici alors en
périscolaire la communauté de communes
de des militants gère cinq pôle
périscolaire sur l'ensemble de son
territoire
délègue ses activités euros un organisme
spécialisé notamment ici sur notre
territoire les francas et propose des
activités sportives des activités
culturelles comme par exemple sur ce
site cet été a été réalisé une fresque
est aussi des activités pédagogiques
éducatives et puis il ya évidemment la
cantine c'est important milieu rural
bien sûr que la cantine est très
importante parce que la plupart des
parents travaillent à 30 km dans les
villes les plus proches belfort
montbéliard et bien entendu ils ont
besoin d'un tel service que la cantine
pour accueillir leurs enfants et le
périscolaire au delà des heures
éducative
merci beaucoup monsieur omer et puis on
ira justement dans la comptine tout à
leur road
c'est à vous et oui on va vous retrouver
tout à l'heure
maxime et on va continuer bien sûr à
parler de cette rentrée scolaire si
particulière mais pour l'heure il est
midi place à l'actualité
[Musique]
midi pile bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez vous êtes bien sur france 3
franche comté à vos cartables à vos
crayons c'est le jour de la rentrée
scolaire une rentrée masquer une rentrée
chamboulé on va en reparler dans
quelques minutes
mais tout d'abord fait un point sur le
reste de l'actualité est au coeur de
l'actualité est bien toujours et encore
le masque à compter d'aujourd'hui il
devient obligatoire dont le centre ville
de besançon comme à montbéliard vers la
boucle dans la boucle près du parc
micaud dans le quartier battant vous ne
pouvez plus sortir non masqué sinon il
vous en coûtera 135 euros
avec ou sans masque vous pouvez avoir
les yeux un peu plus rivés sur le
compteur si vous passez dans le jura
puisque vous pouvez à compter
d'aujourd'hui et bien dépassé les 80
km/heure aller jusqu'à 90 et ce sur 300
kilomètres de routes
voyez les explications de marie soyez et
jean louis sainte à une simple rotation
et c'est désormais officiel depuis ce
matin les automobilistes peuvent rouler
à 90 km/heure sur certaines routes du
jura
une mesure qui semble faire l'unanimité
les limitations à 80 sur certaines
routes c'était trop c'est trop trop bas
sachant qu'en plus on a beaucoup une
fois qu'on est passé à 80 qui roulait à
70 notamment les personnes assez âgées
donc non je trouve ça bien que sur
certains axes reprennent à 90 mais là
moi je viens de faire la queue crotenay
pont du navoy pro du nord-ouest
champagnole taquin 90 ça lieu de quoi en
tout ce sont 300 km de routes
départementales qui repasse tôt 90 km
heure soit environ 10% du réseau 400
panneaux ont été changés plusieurs
adaptations fait
coût total de l'opération 40000 euros
deux ans après l'abaissement de la
vitesse maximale autorisée décidées par
le gouvernement
le conseil départemental du jour
un plus faire marche arrière on a jugé
quand même que cette mesure du 80 km et
est particulièrement contraignante pour
pour les territoires ruraux au
territoire la voiture le moyen de
mobilité est essentielle
donc il était clair que une nouvelle
contrainte de limitations de vitesse
étaient guère supportable par nous
administrer près d'une vingtaine de
départements français sont déjà revenus
ou 90 km heure sur une partie de leurs
raisons on quitte le jura retour sur les
bancs de l'école ou plutôt la cour de
récréation du groupe scolaire de saint
barthélemy nous sommes dans les vosges
saônoises pour parler de cette rentrée
scolaire si particulière et nous sommes
avec le directeur de l'école nicolas 10
quais lukasik on va reparler un petit
peu vous me l'avez dit tout à l'heure
mais pour ceux qui prennent le journal
en cours comment s'est passé l'accueil
et on imagine notamment l'accueil avec
les tout-petits eux n'ont pas de masque
vous vous en avez ils ont pas eu un peu
peur ce matin ils nous regardent
toujours un aigle les yeux un petit peu
plus écarter que d'habitude et nous
justement on essaie d'attraper leur
regard pour les rassurer et globalement
ça s'est très très bien passé
comment vous faites est ce qu'il ya on
parle de ce qu'il faut éviter de brasser
les élèves
ça veut dire quoi qu'il ya des
récréations par exemple différentes en
fonction des classes exactement on a des
récréations qui sont échelonnées sur la
journée et puis on essaie de séparer les
différents bâtiments et d'éviter de
mélanger les enfants par rapport aux
émotions c'est que tout passe quand même
dans le village
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
les enfants sont perturbées ou pas
spécialement finalement une fois qu'on a
expliqué cette histoire de masques et
ben on passe à la rentrée classique là
alors il ya forcément une petite
perturbation pour les champs les
comptines pour certaines voilà et du
coup on essaie de les attraper
différemment mais j'imagine que vous
avez dû aussi préparer ce avec les
enseignants parce que les enseignants
eux doivent être masqué oui tout à fait
on a travaillé en déroute et trouver des
petites des marges pour
voir il a pallié de masse merci beaucoup
on va vous voir justement on va vous
retrouver puisque nous étions hier à vos
côtés pour voir comment s'est préparée
aux côtés des enseignants
cette rentrée scolaire particulière
c'est un sujet d'emmanuel rivalland et
de laurent brocard sur les épaules de ce
directeur on lirait presque le poids
d'une rentrée
écrasé par les consignes sanitaires on
va les installer en salle des maîtres
pas de quoi pourtant effacé l'envi d'une
nouvelle année maintenant on a hâte de
rentrer les petits nous manque quand
même autour de la table ces enseignants
vont discuter gel hydroalcoolique
distanciation mais aussi évoqué le non
dit de cette rentrée les écarts
d'apprentissage duo kobe tu rapport aux
enfants qui ont plus ou moins suivi les
activités avant les vacances et donc il
va faire les identifier vous pouvez
faire des groupes de niveau enfin vous
savez comme d'habitude mais en fait on
renforce la différenciation on essaye de
remettre sur les rails les gamins la
différenciation un mot clé pour ces
enseignants car certains enfants ont
coupé les ponts avec l'école à la fin de
l'année dernière et ya les tests de
positionnement qui vont nous aider quand
même aussi d'avoir un peu comment
comment sont les élèves ce qui pose
vraiment les grosses difficultés
le fossé est et ce avant de dire autres
les élèves qui ont été assidus au
travail parce qu'ils sont développées
dre par leurs parents et ceux qui n'ont
rien fait parce que par pas encadrées et
sur une courte durée
ça ne fera pas avant quelques semaines
je pense rattraper certainement mais
avec la difficulté du masque pour les
enseignants un vrai problème en
maternelle quand avec un groupe
des fois justin mimiques du visage fait
comprend que voilà il ya quelque chose à
faire ou il faut se calmer ou voilà et
c'est ce manque de
de communication non verbale peut
freiner un petit peu le quotidien ces
enseignants s'adapteront une fois de
plus mais ils redoutent un recond
finement l'enseignement à distance les
groupes fracturée qui casse toutes les
dynamiques et nous retrouvons l'une des
enseignantes ici des classes primaires
sylvie lova bonjour bonjour merci nous
accueillir dans votre classe alors quand
on a préparé l'émission vous m'avez dit
qu'en fait c'était notre venue kivu
perturbait beaucoup plus que le masque
absolument ça veut dire que ça se passe
bien pour vous qui a pas d'appréhension
par rapport à ça
pas spécialement la rentrée pour le
moment ce poste relativement normalement
qu'est ce qui a changé on est donc dans
votre salle de classe si on voit
justement que les enfants sont bien
espacées c'est la réorganisation voilà
c'était pas comme ça mon nom c'était pas
du tout comme ça avant je travaillais en
îlots donc des regroupements de quatre à
cinq tables ça c'est quelque chose qui
vous manquent
ah oui le travail en cours et à oui
beaucoup oui oui de pouvoir travailler
en groupe se baser un peu beaucoup enfin
beaucoup mon travail sur le travail de
groupe et et là vous pouvez plus du tout
le faire aussi à partir du moment où on
a pas de règle de distanciation à
respecter dans la cour je pense que dans
la classe on peut se permettre quand
même de travailler bon peut-être pas 4
ou 5 mais au moins deux ans semble donc
il peut y avoir un impact sur la
dynamique du fait justement de cette
épidémie de cette distance obligatoire
et où il a déjà rien que la répartition
comme ça en classe d'encouragement les
élèves à participer de la même façon au
niveau des apprentissages on sait qu'il
ya eu du coup que c'était compliqué avec
le confinement
aujourd'hui vous votre priorité c'est
quoi pendant cette rentrée c'est de
vérifier par un enfant plusieurs qu'ils
soient un petit peu en retard un petit
peu à la traîne
oui bien sûr tout à fait on va utiliser
les tests de positionnement qui a été
proposé par le ministère de l'éducation
nationale pour repérer où en sont les
élèves bon c'est un peu ce qu'on fait
déjà d'habitude mais là d'autant plus et
on va accentuer le le le travail pour
rattraper ce qui n'a pas été bien vous
êtes dati l'année dernière est-ce que ça
a été adapté au niveau des horaires
justement ce que vous pouvez vous avez
un certain volume d'horaires alors on a
le même volume horaire ce qu'on peut
faire c'est démarrer les deux
personnalités plus tôt et on peut
accroître également le volume d'heures
consacrées à l'aide personnalisée vous
avez des inquiétudes vous par rapport à
ça pas vraiment parce que bien marché
pendant le confinement
oui alors après ça dépend ça dépend des
classes ça dépend pour quel enfant il ya
des enfants pour qui ça a très bien
marché pour d'autres il y avait des
problèmes techniques de matériel de
peut-être suivi à la maison c'était pas
forcément évident pour les parents non
plus donc pas pour tout le monde mais
de toute façon aimé vous en
apprentissage on fait des révisions
comme tous les ans de toute manière et
on est vigilant présence et ils seront
obligés de continuer à travailler
merci beaucoup on va retrouver maxime
nouveau qui est avec une représentante
syndicale
oui aux deux nous sommes toujours ici
devant le pôle éducatif saint barthélémy
pour évoquer la question des moyens
d'avec muriel stievenart vous êtes la
déléguée snuipp fsu pour la haute saône
d'abord votre regard d'enseignante
comment s'est passé pour vous cette
rentrée et bien c'est mitigé je dirais
si nous sommes tout à la joie de
retrouver nos classes et nos élèves on
se pose évidemment des questions se noue
à ses protégés protège ton assez nos
élèves
et puis a évidemment le sentiment
d'avoir perdu beaucoup d'enfants l'année
dernière en est il de ceux de ce
rattrapage et ou alors au niveau des
moyens est ce que vous avez l'impression
d'être assez nombreux ou pas assez alors
justement c'est là que se pose quelle se
pose cette question du rattrapage du
retard que l'on a dû qui est dû au
confinement de l'année dernière des
moyens supplémentaires auraient dû être
mises en place bien sûr ce sont les
enseignants qui n'ont pas attendu les
préconisations un ministériel qui sont à
pied d'oeuvre depuis plusieurs jours qui
n'ont pas attendu la prérentrée d'hyères
pour mettre en oeuvre une rentrée
sereine en termes de matériel et en
termes pédagogiques justement malgré des
moyens constamment baisse je parle
notamment du rased le réseau d'aidé aux
enfants en difficulté en dos en haute
saône
nous en comptons 1 pour 1000 élèves ce
qui est très peu skis et qui diminue
manque de personnel accompagnant à un
message voile alors justement vous
parlez une personne accompagnant vous
aimeriez des auxiliaires peut-être pour
aider les enseignants
oui nous avons un manque cruel de
personnel accompagnant un message atsem
avs
si nous voulons respecter les distances
et sciences sociales nous avons besoin
de plus d espace de plus de moyens mais
évidemment de plus de personnels
d'éducation
merci beaucoup mais donc c'était de la
revoilà haute pour ce regard enseignants
sur cette rentrée et on poursuit
justement on poursuit cette discussion
avec l'inspectrice de l'éducation
nationale de luxeuil carol oates bonjour
merci d'être avec nous et puis nous
sommes avec également la présidente des
parents d'élèves de l'association des
parents d'élèves bolivien macedo merci à
vous aussi nous avoir rejoint une
question je me tourne vers vous
justement en tant que directrice de
l'académica spectris academy on
entendait tout à l'heure il ya des
manques de moyens il n'y a pas assez
finalement pour essayer de rattraper le
retard de certains enfants
qu'est-ce qui est mis en place
aujourd'hui par l'éducation nationale
alors pour alors inspectrice de
circonscription c'est madame annie si
l'inspectrice d'académie je vous ai
donné un titre un peu plus alors les
moyens
nous avons déjà eu une carte scolaire
extrêmement bienveillant fin puisque il
n'y a pas eu de fermeture de postes sur
sur le secteur malgré la baisse
d'effectifs qui est assez général dans
ce qui permet d'avoir des classes avec
une moyenne d'à peu près 20 élèves sur
sur ce pôle par exemple mais c'est à peu
près à l'image de ce qui se passe sur le
sur le secteur voir le département et
pour tout ce qui est soutien est ce
qu'il ya eu un volume d'heures qui a été
par exemple augmenter est ce qu'il ya
des moyens mis en place supplément alors
dans le dans le premier degré de toute
façon les enfants ont pu bénéficier déjà
pendant ces vacances de stage de
réussite des vacances apprenantes nous
avons à mettre en place immédiatement
dès la semaine prochaine les hordes apc
et puis enfin si elle préférait
partement par exemple l'alleud
les moyens restants seront distribués ce
soir il y a une politique volontariste
dans le département pour placer des plus
de maîtres queux de classe c'est à dire
des enseignants qui ne seraient pas
affectés sur un poste et qui viennent en
appui de certaines écoles et de
certaines équipes
olivier masset parce que ça c'est une
inquiétude au niveau des parents
d'élèves qui est des élèves qui est
décrochée qui reste à la traîne
oui bien sûr c'est toujours inquiétant
pour tous les pauvres mais je fais
confiance en notre équipe pédagogique et
je sais que malgré tout ce sera récupéré
ils feront leur possible aussi vous le
disiez ici on est dans un an donc on est
dans un pôle éducatif ya une vingtaine
d'élèves c'est un avantage ce pôle
éducatif pour vous dans ces conditions
justement oui oui tout à fait oui oui
quels sont les avantages pour vous pour
vous bah disons que tout est sur place
les enfants sont tous tous ensemble ils
apprendront ils grandiront ensemble né
il ya tout pour moi c'est vraiment il ya
un an il ya un meilleur suivi par
exemple justement dans ce cas où on a
peur qui est du rattrapage on a peur
qu'ils aient des écarts qui se creusent
ce genre de structure ça permet d'avoir
un meilleur suivi que si chacun était
dans une école ou au contraire c'est
peut-être au nom il ya très bon suivi
comme d'habitude comme d'habitude ya
jamais eu pendant le confinement oui
vous avez eu l'impression que c'était
dans le confinement après on a été très
très bien suivis par nos instituteurs
alors on va continuer à parler de
l'intérêt en ce pôle éducatif
mais qui dit pôle éducatif dit souvent
et bien fermetures d'écoles pour
certains villages c'est ce qui se passe
du côté de villers-le-lac comme le monde
ce sujet tourné par marie soyez et
jean-louis cinq ans c'est une page qui
se tourne dans quelques mois des
particuliers s'installeront dans
l'ancienne école du chauffe eau pour les
habitants de ce hameau de villers le lac
l'heure est à la nostalgie ça faisait
vivre le lotissement et puis tous les
gens autour
ça faisait un effet de masse aussi les
gens se connaissaient les gens
discutaient moi je trouve dommage ces
petites structures qui ferment parce que
ça permet à l'enfant de pouvoir être
un peu comme dans une famille c'est
c'est plus intime et puis ils ont plus
de plus vite des copains enfin voilà au
niveau de l'enseignement aussi on peut
plus vite apprendre des choses en 2016
au regard de la baisse des effectifs
l'inspection académique annonce la
fermeture de l'école un collectif de
parents d'élèves se met alors en place
pour contester cette décision
le tribunal administratif de besançon
leur donne raison
avant que la cour d'appel de nancy n'a
nulle ce jugement depuis les enfants du
hameau sont scolarisés dans le centre de
villers-le-lac un bus effectue la
navette
les verts c'est compliqué avec le
déneigement balle sauvons la piscine en
retard donc du coup nous au travail en
arrive en retard aussi et puis on a
toujours peur aussi par rapport à la
neige c'est bien de là c'est que le bus
il est un accident ça c'est clair c'est
toujours une crainte au début des années
2000 la commune de villers le lac
disposer de cinq écoles aujourd'hui elle
n'en compte plus que deux cd projet de
l'éducation nationale que c'est plus
intéressant pour les instituteurs de
travailler en groupe ils font des
projets ils ont des projets que un
instituteur tout seul dans une classe
isolée avec des enfants de tous les
niveaux dans le doubs pour cette rentrée
scolaire 57 ouvertures de classes sont
annoncés contre 19 suppressions les
écoles des ternes au et de déserts
villers devrait elle définitivement
ferment et retour en haute saône on va
retrouver maxime nouveau qui est avec un
mr le maire de la commune de montceau
qui a perdu justement son école pour et
bien que puissent vivre ce pôle éducatif
woods alors regardez nous avons pénétré
à présent dans la cantine de ce pôle de
saint barthélémy effectivement pour
parler du périscolaire est également de
la création de ce pôle de saint
barthélemy avec le maire de monteux saut
rené deux manches alors il faut le dire
la création de ce pôle elle s'est fait
un peu dans la douleur puisque vous dans
votre village de montaud vous avez perdu
une école c'est vrai nous avons perdu
l'école c'est réellement un déchirement
un crève coeur pourrait dire certains
mais il faut bien voir que aujourd'hui
la société a évolué les formations
l'éducation et les petites communes ne
sont plus en capacité d'offrir une des
structures qui permettent une éducation
performante pour vous ici en zone rurale
c'était indispensable de se regrouper
pour ne pas mourir quelque part c'était
indispensable pour ne pas mourir
effectivement est sûre j'ai tout perdu
eh bien on va reprendre la discussion
avec vous car lé donc vous êtes une des
responsables de l'académie ce genre de
paul où on a donc trois communes avec
des classes de 20 et là c'est vraiment
le modèle qu'il faut développer dans
l'avenir alors en tout cas c'est
beaucoup de plus value pour un
territoire pour comme madame la 10 pour
les équipements pour nous l'offre que
l'on peut faire aux familles sur place
grâce au périscolaire mais moi en tant
qu'inspectrice de l'éducation nationale
c'est surtout la plus value pédagogique
que j'y vois les anciennes en fils on a
une équipe plus de moyens oui par
exemple sur les équipements du numérique
ne serait-ce que ça l'accès aux
nouvelles technologies et les garanties
dans toutes les constructions de
nouveaux pôles mondiale et amassé 2 pour
vous vous habitiez dans un village un
qui a perdu justement son école et
pourtant vous regrettez pas non je ne
regrette pas non parce que vous trouvez
que ça a apporté des choses
supplémentaires à 2 par les structures
de parts comme je vous ai dit l'équipe
pédagogique ou voilà ils manquent de
rien la cantine est juste à côté on a
vraiment tout sur place merci beaucoup
merci à vous c'est toujours trop court
et c'est la fin de cette édition
spéciale mais nous on quitte pas notre
tenue d'écolier on se retrouve ce soir
dès 18h50 dans un lycée cette fois on
sera du côté de belfort bel après midi à
tous
[Musique]